[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
how's life treating you another month
means more video games clambering after
your hard earned cash or chasing after
your parents credit card don't worry I
won't judge how you live your life July
is typically the slowest month of the
year due to e3 fatigue but that doesn't
stop great games from releasing like
Marvel Ultimate Alliance on the Nintendo
switch for instance but as that's only
on switch we won't talk about that in
this video instead let's look at 7 new
games arriving in july 2019 apex legends
looked to be the battle royale game -
toppled fought night when it was first
released back in February the game
mechanics were fantastic the character
design was unique but then lack of
updates saw it slowly fall out of sight
the first battle paths for apex legends
was well simply not good enough in my
opinion and did not reward players with
enough content for the asking price well
things are changing in the apex legends
world the hunt event first tested the
new content style with cosmetic items
given out for completing missions and a
new elite game mode for the ultra sweaty
players to test their skills in this
will be added upon when ranked mode
drops during season 2 so when does it
start
well July the second named battle
charged bringing new daily and weekly
challenges a brand spanking new gun
called the L star with 60 rounds and
full automatic plasma EMG goodness and a
new character - named Watson will this
be enough to bring you back to the game
or keep you playing daily I'm looking
forward to jumping back in on July the
2nd oh and by the way the battle pass
includes highly detailed unlockable
skins like this bad boy I don't even
like caustic but I need that skin
[Music]
I'd like to apologize for the following
60 seconds of jokes
the Wolfenstein series has regularly
received high praise for its Nazi bj
action no I can't do that can i it only
works if you've played Wolfenstein let's
set the scene the main character in the
Wolfenstein series is BJ blast kovitch I
didn't name him that but I'm sure going
to make cheap BJ gags okay the
first-person shooter is one of the
longest-running in history but things
are set to change as Wolfenstein
introduces Youngblood over in France we
find the BJ daughters you can make your
own joke there Jess and solve must now
reclaim Paris from the Nazis and do what
their dad BJ did best suck the life out
of Nazis sorry
okay so jokes aside Wolfenstein
Youngblood introduces new mechanics to
the series with a focus on cooperative
play teamwork reviving allies and the
level design which feels more open world
than ever and less claustrophobic than
previous entries in the series although
those sections are definitely still
there this is pretty cool there's a
deluxe version of the game which allows
you to gift a copy of the game for free
to any of your friends so you can play
as the BJ twins together
Wolfenstein Youngblood releases on July
26th on ps4 PC Xbox one and switch as a
sub thought here I always feel that by
putting one of the older Wolfenstein
games on PS Plus or games with gold will
show so many new players how good these
games actually are but opinions like
this are why I'm a youtuber and they
have real jobs
[Music]
let's move our attention away from
first-person shooters and on to sea of
solitude releasing on July the 5th sea
of solitude is an action-adventure
single-player experience which looks at
mental health and in particular
loneliness in this world being alone
turns the inhabitants into monsters
there's a few unique mechanics which
deserve praise for example the weather
changes according to either the main
character's feelings or the emotions of
other characters nearby if there's a
storm brewing and things are getting
dark be careful where you go next
another mechanic is the water level
which fluctuates as Kaye understands her
emotions this game can be easily spoiled
so let's not talk anymore sea of
solitude releases on the ps4 Xbox one
and PC on July the 5th oh and sea of
solitude retails for about one third of
the price of a triple-a game so over
here in the UK it's only twenty pounds
have you ever played Dragon Quest
builders how can I explain it
it's like Minecraft to cross with a
retro Legend of Zelda title it's a
monumental success in its native Japan
on July the 12th the second game in the
series inspirationally called Dragon
Quest builders to hit stores and judging
by the firm itsu score of 37 out of 40
this is a must play I have no idea why
they score it out of 40 and not ten are
100 so let's convert that percentage
it's a ninety two point five out of 100
whoa so in addition to finding resources
and constructing buildings and equipment
builders to introduces the ability to
fly travel underwater and instantly fast
travel to interested if you have a ps4
or switch you can get your digital hands
on this on July the 12th
[Music]
do you watch stranger things no neither
do hi but at least one person a week
tells me how great it is well on July
the fourth the retro-inspired stranger
things 3 video game drops on ps4 PC Xbox
one switch iOS and Android so basically
anything that has a screen on it
inspired by the late 80s and early 90s
isometric games you're probably too
young to remember but if you're old like
me this will be like a snez nostalgia
punch to the groin the game follows the
format of season 3 of the show so once
again let's not look too deep at the
risk of spoilers July the 4th if you're
interested
Just Cause 4 gets a hit of DLC on July
the 3rd in fact if you have the gold
edition you already have early access
right now but does me immortals and
plebs need to wait until July the 3rd
just goes for the open world destruction
simulator filled with guns and carnage
returns with lost domani us which I'm
going to guess translates to the demons
this DLC is adding the supernatural to
the world and lots of neon by the looks
of things we once again fill the boots
of Rico Rodriguez and attempt to contain
this outbreak vehicles people well
basically anything that moves can be
possessed by the plants boars making
this DLC completely unique to what Just
Cause usually gets us oh and last month
there was a visual update to the entire
Just Cause 4 engine that in itself is
worth of notes shame it didn't look this
good on release day but hey onwards and
upwards los demonios is available to all
from July the 3rd on ps4 PC and Xbox one
[Music]
and to end let's look at a VR game its
Wolfenstein yet again this time though
its cyber pilot releasing on psvr
and PC through VR compatible devices on
July the 26th it's a pretty cool premise
we play as a hacker and Jack into Nazi
war machines and turn them against their
creators pretty straightforward let's
leave the final summation to Year
gustafson if you don't know what you are
missing so there we have it 7 new games
and DLCs to play over july 2019 and
beyond
does anything float your boat this month
i'm tempted to go back to apex legends
for season 2 and maybe one of those
Wolfenstein games I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
as always if you want to talk to me come
find me on twitter i'm adam granade over
there it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]